- Geladas aren't
afraid of all predators.
You're looking at
the Ethiopian wolf.
This occurs on the Guassa,
and it's the rarest
canid in the world.
There's only about 400
remaining in Ethiopia,
and 40 of them are at Guassa.
They're social,
but during the day,
you see them mostly alone
out hunting for rodents.
Back in 2008,
Jeff and I would often
see scenes like this.
Ethiopian wolves
stalking for rodents
in the middle of
herds of geladas.
We didn't really think
much about it at the time,
because we saw it so often.
- [Jeff] We didn't have very
good cameras back then either.
(laughter)
- Clearly.
Years later,
after reading some literature,
we realized that this was a
really weird thing to observe.
To observe this carnivore in
the middle of a herd of monkeys
and they're basically
just ignoring each other.
Why isn't the wolf going
and grabbing a baby gelada
as a snack?
Why isn't it getting chased
off by these monkeys?
So it seemed like a phenomenon
worthy of more study.
So I wrote a grant to
National Geographic,
a Young Explorers Grant,
and in 2011,
we had a reason and some
money to go back to Guassa.
So Jeff and I teamed up again.
On this trip,
we followed wolves
around all day.
Walking dozens of
kilometers a day.
And we watched the
behavior of these wolves
when they were with geladas,
and when they were alone,
so we could make a comparison.
What we found is that these
wolves gain an important benefit
by the presence of the monkeys.
So they spend more of
their effort foraging
when they're near monkeys,
and they also catch more
rodents per unit time.
But they can't do anything
when they're among the monkeys.
They have to adhere to
certain rules of engagement.
So they can't move too fast.
They're not allowed to run.
And if they get within two
or three meters of a monkey,
they get chased off.
As far as we can tell,
the monkeys don't get anything
really positive or negative
out of this.
But this is a very rare kind
of mixed species interaction.
To have a predator stalking
among a potential prey species,
peacefully ignoring each other.
So we wrote up a scientific
paper about this,
submitted it.
It was published in a
journal of mammalogy.
And when the paper came out,
we also got some press
that really surprised us.
Are monkeys
domesticating wolves?
Now this was really surprising
because we hadn't mentioned
the D word anywhere,
and I can tell you for a fact
that this is not occurring.
There we go.
So as far as we know,
this kind of interaction is
actually unique to the Guassa,
it only happens at the Guassa.
This is because of the
fragmented species ranges
of Ethiopian wolves and geladas.
But we can suppose
that in the past,
maybe this interaction
was more widespread.
And some supporting evidence
for this comes from a mosaic
that's 2000 years old that
you actually saw earlier.
This mosaic depicts the Nile.
And toward the top,
we have the origin of the Nile
in the Ethiopian highlands.
I'll direct your attention
to two sets of
archers on the left,
and then near the rocky
outcropping in the middle there.
So we see on the left,
the sphingia.
The sphinx monkey of earlier.
And on the right,
the Ethiopian wolf.
So I think it's striking
that 2000 years ago,
artists were portraying these
species in the same frame,
just like in Jeff's photographs.
This highlights to me
what's really special
about the Guassa.
It preserves not only
species diversity
and genetic diversity,
but a different
kind of diversity
which is behavioral diversity.
This is what allows animals to
adapt to changing conditions,
and that's really important
going into the 21st century.
- I was always
frustrated coming back
from some of these trips,
trying to talk about concepts
like behavioral diversity,
or just describing
the scenes that I saw.
And I dealt with this by
turning towards photography.
Since 2008 and our
crappy camera technology,
we got some newer cameras
and we had a lot of
time in the field.
And I found this was a
nice way to intersect
my scientific work with
communicating this work
to other people.
And it's been a very fruitful
kind of collaboration
between these two ideas.
It's a great way to improve
the messaging of science,
but many of the photos
that you've seen today
are end products.
They don't start out like this.
A photo for me often
starts off as an idea.
I see something,
I'm like I wanna capture
the essence of that.
And we can just
kind of explore this
in a very simple example.
I like watching geladas
jump across streams.
To me it's interesting,
it's a cool dynamic behavior,
and I wanted to
take a picture of it
that just captured
the way I felt.
And I tried and tried and tried,
and some of these are
interesting pictures perhaps
but they didn't quite connect.
And I ran through trying
an infrared camera,
long exposures,
cutting geladas heads off.
But when it comes to this
to get a nice picture,
it requires persistence.
And for all of these
it's just trial and trial
and trial and mostly failure.
Eventually I end up with
a picture like this.
Which is not a perfect
picture by any means,
but it's much closer to the
feeling that I wanted to capture
with the monkey jumping
across the stream.
So I've learned an immense
amount about photography
by partnering with
other photographers.
I remember I first came back
from the monkey-wolf project
Vivek and I were doing
solely as researchers,
and had this huge
collection of photographs,
and I was showing them
to a couple of people.
And I met this guy,
Trevor Frost.
And he took a look
at the pictures,
like oh that seems like a
pretty interesting place.
Have you thought about trying
to do a photo essay of that?
To kind of describe the
place in more detail.
I was like I have
thousands of pictures.
Like it's already a photo
essay just pick a couple.
He's like I don't think you
understand how this works.
Why don't we write a grant
and we can go back together
and try to tell this
story professionally?
I was like wait they give
you grants for photography?
I had this very biologist
centric view of the world
and so this was
illuminating for me.
So Trevor and I wrote a grant,
and we were funded by
National Geographic
to go try to capture
this environment.
So with Vivek we headed
back to the field
and Trevor started teaching
me some new techniques,
like this camera trap set up.
Where you have a DSLR,
one of these big fancy
cameras with an infrared beam,
and you have to
practice walking through
triggering the infrared
beam to get it just right
so you can get a
spectacular photo.
I struggled at first initially,
even with opening
the camera trap box.
I think I stabbed my hand with
my Leatherman pretty good.
I was worried that
was gonna get infected
but it wasn't so bad.
And after just setting it up,
and waiting and
tweaking and tweaking,
eventually we ended up
with a photo like this.
Which was our camp staff
bringing their kids to work,
and they knew that we set up
an automatic camera machine,
and they're like oh we
can trigger this camera
any time we want?
This is great.
So they had their kids walk
through it all the time.
And then they
would borrow AK-47s
from their neighbors (laughter)
and pull that out,
so we'll have a
couple of printouts
for those guys
when we head back.
But the real intention of
this is to get up close
and personal with wildlife
that you couldn't otherwise.
To give you a sense
of their space,
and their environment.
And this is the type of picture
that we were looking for.
An Ethiopian wolf,
the rarest canid on the
planet in the Guassa.
So one day I had a
happy intersection
of science and photography.
I was following a wolf around,
trying to see if it
would have one of these
monkey-wolf interactions to
try to get a picture of it.
When a saw a female walk
off from the gelada herd.
And this is bizarre behavior.
It sets off all sorts of alarm
bells in my biologist's brain
being like
something's happening,
what's going on,
all right bailing on wolf.
I went over and I watched her.
She started arching her back,
and lying down and standing up,
and I realized oh my god,
this monkey is
about to give birth.
So I gave her her space,
took my telephoto lens,
I stood back and
with shaking hands
captured this image sequence.
So it's incredibly
rare to see a primate
give birth in the wild.
I was very excited
about these images
for aesthetic purposes,
I thought it really spoke
visually to a process
that most people
don't get to see.
But I also sensed that there
was great scientific value
in these images,
having talked to
other researchers
that have worked at
this site before.
So I was kind of equally
excited about what this means
to kind of our
broader understanding.
Over the past ten years,
scientists at Guassa have
witnessed 15 live births.
Which is the largest,
or one of the largest
catalogs of live births
in wild primates from
anywhere on the planet.
We recently wrote up a paper
kind of describing this process
and it's now a part of
the scientific literature
looking at comparative
birth processes in primates.
Vivek and I are always
trying to think of ways
to combine our
photography with science.
Here's another National
Geographic funded project
that we came up with.
It's a 3D imaging system
that allows you to capture
the dimensions of
wild living primates,
without having to resort
to any invasive procedures.
Basically you can
reconstruct a 3D version
of what you're looking at
by taking multiple pictures
of the same thing from different
angles at the same time.
This is one of our
earlier versions,
we have a more
complex one built now.
And this is an active project
that we're still working
on at the moment.
But we have some promising
preliminary results
and we're looking
forward to taking
these kind of remote
measurements of morphology
and combining them with the
long term behavioral data set
that we have at Guassa.
It's a really
exciting intersection
of photography and science.
But this brings us
towards the end of our day
on the high plateau.
The sun is starting
to set in the west,
and it casts a huge shadow
onto the Rift Valley below
and the farms that
are down there.
We'll walk with the
geladas back towards
their sleeping cliffs,
and we'll leave them there.
It's a routine that
we do everyday,
we'll pick them up
again in the morning.
And they don't
seem to really care
whether we're with them or not.
They just go about
their typical business.
And we can hear this happening
even long after
we've walked away.
Hundreds of meters
back towards our camp,
you can still hear them
going about their transition
from day into night.
(monkeys chattering)
- So tonight we've walked
you through a day in the life
of a gelada and the
people who study them.
We've shown you some science,
and some intimate
portraits of behaviors
that seem to appear
nowhere else on Earth.
Over the past few years,
I've grown very appreciative
of integrating science
and photography together to
not only discover something,
but then tell a story about it,
whether it's through
data and statistics
or through pictures.
Jeff and I always love
returning to the Guassa.
Cause in a lot of ways,
everything is kind of the same.
We see some of the
same individuals,
the routine is more or
less the same year to year.
But the Guassa is also changing.
And it's changing rapidly.
Today there's power
lines and roads
that go through part of it.
Connecting the people
living near the Guassa
with the outside world.
And it's not only the
landscape that's changing,
but also the perceptions of
the local community members.
Take Taso here.
He's worked for our staff
for seven or eight years now,
and the truth is,
when he was a young kid,
he hated geladas.
They raided his crops and
he would run after them
with stones and try to hit them.
But over the years,
his perspective has changed.
He's spent a lot of
hours with the monkeys,
and he's watched
their individual
personalities develop,
and these bonds between mothers
and infants develop as well.
And he even tells us that
now when I see monkeys,
I see what makes
us human basically.
We've also talked about the
factors that affect species
and their ability to
persist in the 21st century.
Geography,
climate,
and the local community
of plants and animals.
And to that we can
add another element
which is the human community.
The Guassa has persisted for
400 years across revolutions,
and famines,
all because of local
engagement of the people
with their land.
And of course today we're facing
a major conservation crisis.
Humans are shaping the natural
world like never before.
And a lot of these problems
have global solutions,
like climate change.
But for others,
perhaps the Guassa
provides a lesson.
I think the Guassa shows us
that going into
the 21st century,
local small scale conservation
has a major role to play.
Thank you.